we decided to reshoot a bunch of our old
covers these Playboy models are back and
proving their timeless beauties playboy
is throwing it back to the 70s 80s and
90s inviting seven models who graced the
cover decades ago to recreate their
iconic photos and the results are
stunning it's good to have the girls
back remember playboy mogul Hugh
Hefner's second wife Kimberly Conrad
Hefner their son Cooper is now Playboy's
chief creative officer and asked his mom
to participate in the shoot himself a
pretty unconventional one Mother's Day
president but she said yes the 54 year
old beauty who lived in the mansion
during her marriage to Hef and was
featured on the August 1988 cover tells
playboy she never minded the other
playmates being around quote it was
always an open door and open gate it was
just a different time you know it's
wonderful the heavy bag
Renee Tennyson was featured on the June
1990 cover making history as the first
african-american Playmate of the Year
she tells the mag it didn't come without
controversy quote some women were saying
I was being objectified but I said well
if you're pro-choice shouldn't I have
the right to choose what I want to do
former playmate Candice Collins
Lisa Matthews and Charlotte Kemp also
proved they can still strike a pose
you